senator schumer's right we are in a
whole new world now let's be blunt about
it
we saw a horrifying storm last night
unlike anything we have seen before
and this is a reality we have to face
unfortunately the price paid
by some new yorkers
was horrible and tragic we have now lost
nine new yorkers to this storm
nine people who were alive at this exact
moment yesterday
no idea that such a horrible fate could
befall them
families in mourning right now we need
to be there for them and for all the new
yorkers who right now are dealing with
the results of this horrifying storm
i want to thank senator schumer
we spoke earlier today i know he will
get us the maximum federal aid our
homeowners need it our business owners
need it people are going through hell
right now they need help
i thank president biden and senator
schumer for being willing immediately to
help governor hokul we spoke repeatedly
last night this morning thank you for
your leadership thank you
for the way the state of new york
responded
we are truly all in this together
and storms affect all of us but what
we've got to recognize is the suddenness
the brutality of storms now it is
different
a record set two weeks ago another
record set now rainfall like we haven't
seen
ever before
this is
the biggest wake-up call we could
possibly get
we're going to have to do a lot of
things differently and quickly
but what is a constant is our first
responders
i want to thank the men and women
of
the fdny ems
nypd environmental protection all the
agencies that were out in force last
night
rescuing hundreds and hundreds of new
yorkers
so many lives were saved because of the
fast courageous response of our first
responders people
help from a subway train
safely people helped out of a car in a
flooded area this happened literally
hundreds of times last night
and god bless our first responders who
are there
we've got a lot of work to do right now
to help new yorkers recover
but we also have a lot of work to do to
change the very approach i agree with
the governor it's time for an entirely
different approach because
we're getting a signal here
and it's not going to be easy we're
going to need all that help possible
from the federal government
but in our time we have to make this
change
we've gotten the message we have to make
a change
to protect the lives of the people of
the city
thank you